[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález colombia cumple
más de una semana de paro nacional en
medio de manifestaciones contra el
gobierno del presidente iván duque y en
un creciente ambiente de tensión social
las protestas pacíficas y válidas han
sido ensombrecidas por actos vandálicos
robos y también con violentos choques
con la policía y las fuerzas especiales
del esmad desencadenando el uso de la
fuerza por parte de los militares hacia
los ciudadanos y también ha habido una
serie de violaciones de los derechos
humanos de parte y parte por ese motivo
varios organismos internacionales y
también algunos gobiernos han criticado
la situación y han instado al gobierno
colombiano a intentar disminuir el uso
de la fuerza
la ong temblores ha hecho un seguimiento
a través de esta semana a través de su
plataforma grita y lleva un punteo
minucioso de los hechos de violencia a
lo largo de esta semana alejandro lanz
va a estar con nosotros más adelante
aquí en este programa para profundizar
en las cifras y para hacer el análisis
pero veamos los números para ponernos en
contexto hasta el momento mil
708 son los casos de violencia policial
denunciados 222 víctimas de violencia
física por parte de la policía 37 son el
número de víctimas de violencia homicida
por parte de la policía a 831 las
detenciones arbitrarias en la siguiente
gráfica vemos que son 312 las
intervenciones violentas por parte de
las fuerzas de seguridad 22 víctimas han
dejado las agresiones a ciertos
ciudadanos que han tenido agresiones con
sus ojos han perdido la visión o han
perdido sus ojos o han resultado heridos
110 casos de disparos de arma de fuego
por parte de la policía y 10 víctimas de
violencia sexual por parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad ese es el balance
que dejan una semana de enfrentamientos
también 540 policías han resultado
heridos a nivel nacional
pues hay que añadir que recientemente la
fiscalía general de colombia también
imputará a varios agentes de la policía
por tres homicidios durante estas
protestas lo dijeron a lo largo del día
de hoy la otra cara de la moneda es el
vandalismo y los daños millonarios que
han dejado a aquellos que han usado
estas protestas pacíficas para agredir y
robar también para destruir algunos
locales para destruir las estaciones de
policía conocidas en colombia como cai
allí 540 policías policías han resultado
heridos tal vez un poco más y las cifras
estuvieran más actualizadas por parte
del ministerio de defensa de colombia
diego molano fue que dio a conocer esta
cifra pero eso fue hace ya unas cuantas
horas asimismo la defensoría del pueblo
elevó a 112 el número de personas
desaparecidas a lo largo de esta semana
en estos enfrentamientos la oficina de
la alta comisionada de la onu para los
derechos humanos expresó su preocupación
por la actuación de las fuerzas del
orden en colombia la unión europea y
otras organizaciones de los derechos
humanos también denunciaron el uso
desproporcionado de la fuerza por parte
de la policía y de éstas
de seguridad conocidas como smart para
analizar este tema entonces hemos
invitado ya les avanzaba a alejandro
lance les defensor de los derechos
humanos y es el codirector de la ong
temblores que como lo mencioné ha
documentado estos casos de abuso
policial y también está con nosotros
invitados para este análisis ricardo
ferrero el ex ferro perdón él es el
representante a la cámara por el partido
oficialista centro democrático les en
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y sus comentarios en las redes
sociales en la recuerdo estamos en
facebook y no se encuentran en instagram
y en twitter como arroba france24 quien
bajo ese arroba santi logo la etiqueta
es numeral el debate efe 24 tenemos allí
pues más información para destacar sobre
estos temas y sobre el cubrimiento que
ha hecho france24 sobre estas
manifestaciones en colombia con un
equipo periodístico desplegado en cali y
otro en bogotá tenemos el tema y tenemos
la información quiero comenzar primero
para abrir el debate conocer las
opiniones de los invitados en torno al
tema alejandro lance
opinión sobre lo que está sucediendo en
colombia sobre estas acusaciones que hay
de violaciones a los derechos humanos y
del uso desproporcionado de la fuerza
según indican los números que su ong ha
revelado por parte de la policía y de
las fuerzas de seguridad
bueno primero que todo muchísimas
gracias por la invitación y un saludo
representante del centro democrático
nosotros desde temblores ong venimos
registrando desde hace más de cuatro
años como la fuerza pública ha
violentado a la ciudadanía de una manera
arbitraria y se ha comportado de esta
manera agrediendo y violentando a
ciertos grupos sociales así lo
publicamos hace poco en un informe
titulado bolillo dios y patria en donde
documentamos como en los últimos tres
años después de la implementación del
nuevo código de policía se cometieron
289 homicidios presuntamente cometidos
por la fuerza pública 39 mil 613 hechos
de violencia física y 102 hechos de
violencia sexual nosotros hemos hecho
mucho énfasis en decir en que estas
cifras son provenientes del mismo estado
a través de derechos de petición
brindados por medicina legal esto quiere
decir que el estado está en la misma
capacidad de generar estos diagnósticos
y de aterrizar esta situación a un
cambio de la estructura política y
arquitectónica del estado colombiano
para solucionar un problema de fondo que
es el problema estructural de la
violencia policial contra ciertos grupos
sociales
del 21 de noviembre y desde el 9 de
septiembre nosotros hemos venido
reportando la violencia por parte de la
fuerza pública en las protestas sociales
y el 21 de noviembre tuvimos unos
episodios de violencia muy fuerte es el
asesinato de dylan cruz después vino el
9 de septiembre y nunca creímos que
podía haber algo peor que lo que sucedió
el año pasado y con mucha tristeza
tenemos que denunciar que en lo que va
del paro que empezó el 28 vamos a 32
strauss por nuestras plataformas
cometidos presuntamente por miembros de
la fuerza pública
representante ferro cuál es su
perspectiva sobre la situación que se
está denunciando en torno a los derechos
humanos y al uso de la fuerza por parte
de las fuerzas de seguridad en colombia
con la víbora noches para usted
el panelista que está en este momento
también con nosotros como todo el equipo
de el canal y por supuesto para todos
los televidentes yo estoy muy preocupado
por las vidas humanas que se están
perdiendo en colombia
con uniforme o sin uniforme son vidas
humanas que se están perdiendo en
colombia hoy tenemos decenas de madres
de policías de personas que están
protestando de civiles
y están llorando a sus hijos y eso no
puede seguir sucediendo aquí nosotros no
podemos
incendiar más el país de lo que está
sino todo el contrario tenemos que
llamar a todos a la calma para que aquí
la única solución que hay para poder
avanzar en las respuestas de las
soluciones que necesita el país es a
través del diálogo hay que dialogar al
saldar y no podemos seguir permitiendo
que delincuentes que terroristas filtren
las protestas pacíficas que vayan en
contra de la fuerza pública se vayan en
contra de los edificios oficiales se
vayan en contra de los comercios se
vayan en contra de todo el país y que
tampoco del otro lado haya también que
mala utilización o exceso en la fuerza
por parte del controlador del público
aquí el llamado es para todos los
sectores aquí si queremos realmente
aportar ya el país
podemos tomar partido con un lado por el
otro tenemos que propender porque siendo
el mismo país siendo los mismos
colombianos entre todos nos podamos
sentar y poder solucionar los problemas
que hay lo que no puede ocurrir es que
hoy estemos peleando por un problema si
mañana evoluciona el problema
esto ya nace otro y pasaba monedas de
otros y refrigeración antes viene hace
otro y para solucionar todo el problema
la única alternativa real y había de
hecho hay que sentarnos a dialogar
representante ferro sigo con usted a gol
a la ronda a la inversa
qué opinión tiene usted sobre estas
críticas que ha habido por parte de la
comunidad internacional principalmente
por organismos internacionales la
organización de naciones unidas amnistía
internacional human right watch sobre la
situación de derechos humanos en
colombia a lo largo de esta semana y
este uso según califican
desproporcionado de la fuerza por parte
de los militares le han llamado la
atención al gobierno colombiano y le han
pedido disminuir la tensión que hay en
el país cuál es su opinión al respecto
y me parece importante que se revise
todo con el contexto aquí se han
cometido errores de lado y lado aquí no
solamente se puede señalar a uno de los
dos lados es que acaso tiene
presentación de unas personas unos
terroristas le prendan fuego a un oscar
con policías adentro efectivamente
estando unos seres humanos dentro de una
de estaciones de policía le prendan
fuego para considerar a las personas que
se encontraban el adentro aquí también
hay unos temas muy delicados que van más
allá de la protesta pacífica y por eso
es que es importante que todos estos
organismos internacionales puedan tener
un contexto de lo que está pasando en
colombia aquí al final no habrá ni
vencedores ni vencidos
vamos a terminar 22 porque finalmente el
que va a perder es el país 15 kaiser se
quemaron hace dos noches en bogotá dos
que yo atacaron mejor hace dos noches en
la ciudad de bogotá el transporte
público ha avanzado en cali una ciudad
cerrada en la comunidad perdiéndose
incomunicados para poder ingresar y
sacar alimentos para poder ingresar
combustible esos temas no pueden ocurrir
pero yo vuelvo grave al principio es que
aquí no se trata es de señalar quién se
noche no tiene responsabilidad y si la
comunidad internacional quiere realmente
aportar la solución del problema que
existe en colombia en este momento debe
ser imparcial debe mirar todo lo que
está ocurriendo porque de lo contrario
sencillamente se va a 6000 incendiando
el país
serbia adentro desde afuera pero eso
está por perdidos para que el incendio
el país alejandro en la ciudad de bogotá
en la capital colombiana le preguntó
ustedes ya decíamos algunas de las
cifras
y han dado a conocer estos numerosos
casos de diferentes hechos que han
ocurrido a lo largo de esta semana en
colombia ya lo decía el representante
esto es de lado y lado aquí no solamente
hay un bando que está vulnerando a los
derechos humanos ahí también de parte y
parte
dentro de esa investigación ese conteo
que ustedes han hecho han evidenciado
algún tipo de violaciones por parte de
los manifestantes o de estos grupos que
aparentemente están infiltrando estas
protestas pacíficas ciudadanas y que han
desencadenado estos hechos de violencia
y de vandalismo en diferentes ciudades
del país
bueno primero que todo permítanme decir
dos cosas y es que nosotros desde
temblores ong hemos rechazado
enfáticamente todos estos actos de
vandalismo que han puesto en riesgo la
vida de los policías así como también
hemos rechazado el policía de la
siguiente fue asesinado en el marco de
las protestas apuñalado a comienzos de
esta jornada del paro por personas que
cometieron efectivamente ese delito que
debe ser tipificado por el código penal
y judicial izado efectivamente pero
permítanme explicar aquí un contexto
importante y es que esto no se trata de
lado y lado y de dos bandos aquí hay un
estado social de derecho que es el
estado colombiano que detenta el poder
de la fuerza pública y que debe cuidar
la vida y la seguridad de sus ciudadanos
y el estado colombiano ha emitido
comunicaciones muy complicadas
confundiendo lo que es la protesta
porque es social pacífica y el
vandalismo y nosotros venimos
insistiendo entre en que mientras el
estado y las instituciones y los
partidos políticos del gobierno no
diferencia en la protesta social
pacífica de los actos vandálicos no va a
poder perseguir judicialmente a los
primeros y proteger a la
constitucionalmente a los segundos y
esto lo vimos con mucha preocupa
desde el primer día del paro se tomaron
un banco y unas personas haciendo actos
vandálicos que debieron ser
judicializadas por la fuerza pública y
ese banco se lo tomaron y no hubo la
fuerza que lo repeliera y en cambio si
hemos visto más de 236 intervenciones
violentas del esmad que quiere decir que
están las marchas pacíficas y llegan las
tanquetas a irrumpir esta movilización
pacífica ya dispersar la ya impedir la
movilizarse y eso es un problema
estructural de este estado colombiano no
se trata de que unas vidas valgan más y
otras vidas valgan menos nosotros
rechazamos la muerte rechazamos la
violencia rechazamos la privación
arbitraria de la vida pero cuando el
estado está cometiendo de esta manera
tan sistemática las privaciones
arbitrarias a la vida de quienes salen a
las calles a manifestarse y ya no
solamente de quienes salen a
manifestarse sino también de personas
que están pasando por el espacio público
por la falta de conocimiento y de iu y
de profesionalismo en el uso de estas
armas de aparente letalidad reducida es
una situación muy preocupante de la que
estamos bien
y por eso es que los organismos de
control internacional están con los ojos
encima de colombia y todos los medios y
la prensa internacional han puesto sus
ojos encima lo aprovecho también esta
entrevista para agradecerle porque
gracias a los medios internacionales es
que se está visibilizando esta situación
porque aquí en las noticias en colombia
lo único que ha primado es el vandalismo
el vandalismo debe ser rechazado y
judicial izado pero insisto en que
mientras el estado y el partido de
gobierno no logre separar estas dos
cosas una cosa clasificada en el código
penal y otra cosa protegida
constitucionalmente que es la protesta
social no vamos a poder avanzar de
ninguna manera y aquí lo que está
sucediendo en el país es que la gente
tiene mucha rabia y mucha tristeza
contra la policía porque ha visto los
vídeos de como todas las noches la gente
llama pidiendo auxilio y alerta por los
asesinatos que está cometiendo por los
actos de tortura los hechos de violencia
sexual y todas las pérdidas de las
lesiones oculares que se han venido
generando representante ferrón a las
críticas que hacen
y que tal vez algunos analistas
analistas piensan que es el punto de
partida para comenzar un diálogo que
lleve a buen puerto y que solucione ya
esta situación crítica que está viviendo
colombia es que el gobierno haga
precisamente esa diferencia que estaba
mencionando alejandro entre los que
salen a manifestarse de manera pacífica
que están dentro de la constitución y
son avalados dentro de las leyes
colombianas y las otras personas que
salen y aprovechan esta coyuntura de
este momento para delinquir y también
que escuche a los colombianos le parece
a usted que el presidente le ha faltado
oír a los colombianos y hacer esa
diferencia para ver cómo puede empezar a
solucionar la crisis y empezar a bajar
un poco a mitigar los ánimos en el país
ayer yo creo que lo de nacional cen algo
se ha caracterizado así en la capacidad
de escucha que ha tenido para la muestra
sencillamente que desde el domingo
anterior cuando se dijo que el problema
verdad la reforma tributaria del domingo
se retiró la reforma y apenas derretido
la reforma ya entonces el problema de la
reforma tributaria ya el problema de
edad que se ha presentado tras reforma y
el problema de la 88 entonces que tenga
que renunciar el ministro
hacia la isla anunció el ministro de
hacienda y buen teatro hasta el día
siguiente hay otro problema yo lo que
veo también en elche se quiere politizar
el derecho a la protesta y el derecho a
la protesta pacífica de estar por encima
de la politización imágenes de usted
donde los protestantes pacíficos que
tienen unos unas peticiones legítimas
por demás terminan siendo
instrumentalizados con los políticos el
gravísimo para el país y se deslegitima
la protesta en su esencia entonces aquí
no solamente que el gobierno nacional
sepa diferenciar y yo aquí utilizó el
término más fuerte porque aquí hay que
llamar las cosas por su nombre no
podemos con el feminismos tratado y
tratar de tapar el sol con un dedo una
cosa es la propuesta pacífica y otra
cosa es el terrorismo urbano que se ha
venido tomando las calles de colombia
durante estas últimas protestas desde
9 septiembre anterior en donde hubo las
primeras demostraciones de terrorismo
urbano en colombia cosa que antes no
existía el tren está en marcha también
lo hemos visto y repito respeto la
protesta por significa respeto a los que
están protestando pacíficamente tienen
todo su derecho de hacerlo pero eso no
significa que no haya otras personas que
estén ahí camuflados o escondidos o
aprovechando las circunstancias para
hacer terrorismo urbano porque el
llamado también es para los protestantes
pacíficos para que denuncien esas
personas que no están protestando
pacíficamente que no se vuelvan
cómplices de esos terroristas urbanos
que no se les complique de esos personas
que quieren ver las víctimas el estado
colombiano
tan importante como virtud es tan
importante para el país y para cualquier
país como lo demás policía y yo
y quiero en lo que escuchaba ahora él
al otro invitado y elche perdone aquí
hay millones de colombianos que queremos
a nuestra policía nacional que
respetamos a la policía y que nos
sentimos tranquilos gracias a que existe
la policía en colombia porque la policía
ha abundado en medio de esta dificultad
que ha vivido el país en los últimos
días un rol fundamental que mantener la
vida de tres cientos de miles de
colombianos que quieren ir a trabajar
que quieren poder desarrollar sus
actividades económicas y gracias a que
existe la policía es que lo han podido
hacer porque si no fuera por esta
institución un seguramente estos
terroristas hermanos escondidos en las
velas machetes camuflados en la protesta
social hubiera acabado con la vida de
muchos otros representantes alejandro
que su opinión al respecto estamos
hablando de terrorismo urbano que se ha
infiltrado como lo dice el representante
ricardo ferro a estas marchas pacíficas
tienen evidencia usted
desde que las personas que están
cometiendo estos actos vandálicos son
pertenecientes a grupos delincuenciales
urbanos o de otra índole
primero que todo permite contrarrestar
lo que está diciendo el representante
porque en primer lugar pues yo coincido
con él en que ya la gente no está
saliendo a las calles a protestar por la
reforma tributaria que fue retirada
porque cuando salió a protestar por la
reforma tributaria la policía fue tan
violenta que la nueva agenda de la
protesta social se convirtió en el
derecho a la protesta en sí por el mero
derecho a salir a protestar sin ser
asesinado y violentado por la policía
entonces ese primer punto nos ha dejado
37 homicidios cometidos presuntamente
por parte de la fuerza pública entonces
decir que la policía en colombia está
protegiendo la vida y la integridad de
la gente es una completa falacia hasta
la misma hasta las mismas instituciones
del estado están comenzando a reconocer
estos homicidios a reconocer esta
violencia
y a denunciar también dentro de sus
propios registros que muchas de las
personas han perdido la vida por parte
de la policía y estas personas que han
perdido la vida por parte de la policía
no son ni personas o bandas las e y que
tampoco lo deberían hacer porque si
fueran personas que están incurriendo en
vandalismo deberían ser es judicial
izadas porque aquí no existe la pena de
muerte lo recuerdo y no está en
capacidad la policía de asesinar a
alguien que está cometiendo un acto
vandálico sino que debes capturarla y
judicial izarla por el delito
correspondiente tipificado el código
penal sino que hemos registrado
manifestantes asesinados que están
pacíficamente movilizándose transeúntes
que están en el espacio público gente
que está en sus casas haciendo y
golpeando una cacerola ha recibido gases
del esmad por parte de la fuerza pública
cuando simplemente está produciendo un
ruido al interior de las viviendas se
están disparando gases lacrimógenos para
apaciguar las voces de la protesta
entonces yo sí creo que aquí hay que
hacer esas claridades y esas diferencias
importantes y también aprovechó para
hacer un llamado al congreso
a la cámara de representantes a que aquí
lo que hay que hacer y ahí y con mucha
urgencia es tramitar una reforma
policial que le garantice a las víctimas
de la violencia por parte de la policía
un acceso efectivo a la justicia que
hemos evidenciado nosotros dentro de
este marco que todos estos procesos
terminan siendo juzgados como actos del
servicio yo le pregunto al representante
si los hechos de violencia sexual son
actos del servicio de la policía y deben
ser juzgados por un tribunal militar si
hace parte de esto como del actuar de la
policía normal y esto constituye un acto
de servicio
estamos en una ruptura total del estado
social de dejar colombia si no ya voy a
hablar del tema de la reforma más
adelante
antes de darle la palabra al
representante ferro quiero preguntarle
pero entonces esas imágenes que veíamos
de personas
incendiando las estaciones de policía en
colombia que son conocidas como cai e
incluso una de ellas con policías
adentro que les tocó salir y que fueron
recibidos por este esta turba que estaba
tratando de tomarse está esta estación y
los hicieron salir porque ya el humo
pues no
permitirá respirar entonces como
entiende uno es escenario bueno este es
un escenario muy complejo de descifrar
nosotros ese día que quemaron ese primer
cow cayenne aures en bogotá
hicimos un tuit denunciando y rechazando
completamente esas imágenes de angustia
que vivieron agentes de la fuerza
pública por parte de la ciudadanía que
arremetieron contra este esté acá y lo
analizaron y terminaron poniendo en
riesgo la vida de los policías en este
momento nosotros creemos que esta no es
ninguna forma legítima de protestar
contra la fuerza pública y por eso es
que se hace necesaria una discusión
política en colombia sobre este debate
de reformar a la policía
quienes pueden estar detrás de esos
hechos ustedes que han estado en terreno
y que tienen acceso a información
cercana de las de las marchas quienes
pueden estar detrás de esos hechos
porque eso también es reprochable
claro es completamente reprochable
nosotros no tenemos información de
inteligencia porque nuestro rol debe de
defender derechos humanos no es tan
grande hemos ejercido durante estos ocho
días el rol de la defensoría del pueblo
que en colombia no existe y estamos
reportando las cifras como si fuéramos
una especie de defensoría pero no
tenemos la capacidad de también ser la
agencia de inteligencia del estado lo
que sí le puedo decir es que si hay una
relación de persecución constante a la
juventud por parte de la fuerza pública
y que los cais se han convertido en una
herramienta de persecución a los jóvenes
nosotros hemos documentado permítame
permítame decirle solamente esta cifra
en 2019 registramos como la policía
interpuso comparendos 200 mil
comparendos por agresión a la autoridad
contra la juventud y en el 2020 con las
medidas extraordinarias de la pandemia
esta cifra se elevó a un millón
doscientos de comparendos hemos
documentado una persecución constante de
la policía a la juventud esto no
justifica de ninguna manera lo que está
sucediendo en los calles pero hay que
abrir un debate público nacional sobre
el actuar entre
sería entre toda la representante
adelante se me acaba el tiempo y
necesito avanzar con el tema de adelante
por lo que es que es muy difícil es muy
difícil hablar porque porque cuando
cuando uno escucha todo esto hombre
realmente yo sí llamó a la sensatez
nosotros no podemos estar siendo
irresponsable un tono era la policía
como si fueran los bastiones unos
delincuentes por dios
este es un mando muy grande que le
estamos haciendo al país estas
instituciones no del link que emiten las
personas las personas que cometan algún
tipo de delitos deben responder a título
personal no como institución donde
hagamos este año a la policía no le
hagamos desde dando al país eso es muy
grave para el país por dios de donde acá
se puede decir que él tiene a con su
energía lo hoy ya que es la forma de
tratar de poner a la juventud en contra
de una institución como la tonicidad eso
no es responsable
y llamó con todo respeto a la ciencia
que llamó a que nosotros no podemos
seguir mirando el país si tenemos la
posibilidad de tener unos espacios
mediáticos a nivel nacional a nivel
internacional nuestra nuestra nuestro
rol y nuestra lo que debemos hacer es
precisamente ser responsable con
nuestras palabras pero llegar a los
extremos y simplemente que limitarse al
lamentar el 16 actos que se cometieron
simultáneamente contra la policía en los
calles de bogotá que son organiza un
vándalo aisladamente eso es un acto
terrorista sincronizado eso de cerrar en
la ciudad de cali en sus cuatro
centrales es un acto terrorista
premeditado eso no son actos aislados
por dios llamó de la verdad a la gente
no sigamos escapa tratando de tapar el
sol con un dedo el gatito yo no quiero
que comemos partido
yo quiero que vemos todas las cosas
pero que tampoco hallamos nosotros
repasá comprando un acto tan
irresponsable como bien contra la
institucionalidad del país
este es un daño que no ya podemos
heredar a colombia ni a las próximas
generaciones de compatriotas legislamos
así te perdona si de pronto hablo
convierte el método me duele mucho mi
país me duele mi país le pregunto a
alejandro ponía sobre la mesa el tema de
un posible debate que puede darse en el
congreso o que llegue esta idea del
congreso esta propuesta de hacer un
debate sobre una reestructuración una
reformulación de la policía en colombia
piensa usted que es el momento de
empezar a plantear estas ideas que tenga
una renovación esta institución
el congreso y el país que tenemos que
estar abiertos a que se presenten
diferentes proyectos de ley en todos los
destinos el tema de la policía abiertos
a que realicemos el tema de la policía
se tiene que realizar y si de mí si se
han cometido errores o se han cometidos
delitos el más grande cometer errores
pues que los responsables paguen por
esos delitos pero también es hora de
realizar la protesta social de colombia
de realizar que es protesta social que
es vandalismo que el terrorismo urbano y
hasta dónde va cal porque tampoco
podemos nosotros conectar con qué
autores intelectuales o cómplices del
terrorismo urbano fácil de agache y que
solamente nos retiramos al tema de los
terroristas o de los autores materiales
si hay autores intelectuales y si hay
cómplices también tienen que ser
responsables porque aquí para poder
lograr el día de mañana que garantice la
vida de los que protestan pacíficamente
es decir es de los primeros
de expulsar de las marchas aquí no
porque meten a estas protestas pacíficas
aquí del tal vez nunca nos entran la
protesta pacífica alejandro su opinión
sobre este tema de la reforma que usted
mismo ponía sobre la mesa de debate
no muchas gracias por la pregunta y
celebro de verdad representante que por
parte del partido de gobierno haya una
alta disposición como acabo de escuchar
de proponer al interior del congreso de
la república una reforma estructural a
la policía nosotros desde temblores ong
venimos tratando de proponer este debate
nacional al país es desde hace más de un
año y medio desde que sucedieron los
hechos del 9 de septiembre y si creemos
que hay que hacer una serie de
modificaciones para garantizar la
justicia y el acceso a la administración
de justicia de las víctimas de violencia
por parte de la policía
por ejemplo mire solamente un dato en el
año 2005 asesinaron a nicolás neira y su
padre duró 16 años en lograr una condena
contra la gente del esmad tuvo que salir
del país amenazado fue víctima de
persecuciones y hostigamientos y esto es
lo que tienen que vivir las personas que
denuncian a la policía cuando son cuando
la policía comete un delito pues hay un
punto central y un eje central que debe
ser el la transformación de la justicia
penal militar y la justicia ordinaria
para que los casos lo que decía antes
cuando son cometidos por parte de la
policía hechos de violencia sexual
tortura
el 9 de septiembre tenemos un hecho por
ejemplo de una periodista que tomó una
fotografía en la macarena y fue llevada
al caí de la macarena desnudada obligada
a hacer cuclillas es delante de todos
los oficiales y este hecho la fiscalía
lo clasificó como un acto de servicio de
la policía y por ende lo llevó a la
justicia penal militar entonces esto es
un eje central importantísimo de la
reforma que debemos discutir en ese
escenario en el escenario del congreso y
para cambiar esto debemos convocar a
todos los sectores políticos y desde la
sociedad civil que es lo que nosotros
somos sociedad civil que tratamos de
generar derechos humanos en letra de
público esa es nuestra propuesta
entonces para y se me acaba el tiempo
para el programa tengo que hacer la
constitución rápidamente 30 seguras para
cada uno representante claro que sigue
entonces aquí en este escenario de
crisis en colombia lo que hemos visto en
las últimas semanas ha sido lamentable
ver a los colombianos luchando entre
ellos en las calles en escenarios que no
habíamos visto con tanta fuerza en los
últimos años
qué va a pasar en este país
yo invito a que nos sentemos a dialogar
no tenemos que estar de acuerdo en todo
lo sentémonos a dialogar si nosotros no
somos capaces de sentarnos a dialogar no
vamos a poder solucionar los problemas
cada vez vamos hacer menos porque ya van
a morir más personas y actualmente no
solamente se están muriendo personas de
la fuerza pública policías sí hijos de
policías como en el tv que llevaba en su
vientre la policía que lo perdió hace
hace unos días representante a una
ganancia por puerta del programa falta
la conclusión alejar adicionalmente por
perdiendo vidas de adultos mayores que
de acuerdo en lo que lo que sigue en
colombia ahorita es hacer una
desescalada de la violencia no podemos
permitir que de ella y de las armas
brigada siga silenciando la vida
nosotros desde temblores venimos
haciendo llamados diarios a que la gente
no salga en las noches a protestar gente
no hay seguridad para la vida
muchas gracias por la sintonía siga con
la programación de france 24
[Música]